and then the media is just like we're
not going to talk about it at all all of
us we're not going to talk about it but
let's talk about Kyrie Irving let's talk
about how Kanye Kanye West is a Nazi
lover
[Music]
so Elon Musk this is breaking news we
finally are doing breaking news
I'm sure we'll still [ __ ] it up somehow
in the way that we're gonna [ __ ] it up
put a note in and this will still be out
in four months but
hopefully you'll see this very soon
um Elon Musk has dropped the Twitter
Files about how Twitter helped to
um cover up the hunter Biden laptop
story during the election in 2020. that
was weird because that was such breaking
news tell them so like do you guys
remember right around election time they
found Hunter Biden Biden's son yeah he
found this they they cracked into his
laptop because he took it in to get it
fixed for a virus and then they had him
if I didn't sleepy with a crack pipe
those videos are crazy pictures of
hookers him [ __ ] some chicks feet
yeah I remember seeing the [ __ ] I
remember being on JK and seeing that
[ __ ] and be like I don't know I just saw
like I guess Russian disinformation I
saw literally Hunter Biden's dick in
some chicks feet but I guess I probably
saw some [ __ ] hey was he packing
that's not the worst thing though I
think the worst stuff was all the uh
conversations and transactions with
Ukraine and stuff like that so I was
like oh funny we're kind of involved in
Ukraine right now how did that happen
Joe Biden taking bribes from the Chinese
government yeah but oh I'm sorry it was
Hunter but also maybe Joe was
um associated with with that so so what
we're about to read is this is per Matt
taibi this is the Twitter files that
have been released from Elon Musk
um this is the first installment in a
series based upon thousands of internal
documents obtained by sources of Twitter
I'm reading little just his thread right
now Twitter files tells an incredible
story from inside one of the world's
largest and most influential social
media platforms it's a frankensteinian
tale of a human built mechanism run out
of the control of this designer Twitter
in its conception was a brilliant tool
for enabling instant mass communication
making a true real-time Global
conversation possible for the first time
its early conception Jesus Christ you've
been in the [ __ ] history lesson and
then Jack Dorsey lost control of his own
business yeah to The Two Towers there
already no Fellowship of the Ring yeah I
mean good Lord okay yeah so I like that
joke so he so I'm skipping a little bit
God damn [ __ ] shut up Elon tell us
the [ __ ] Hunter Biden [ __ ] okay by
2020 requests from connected actors to
delete tweets were routine one executive
will write to another more to review
from the Biden team and then the reply
would come back handled so they're
working in conduct conjunction with the
DNC at this point so then that's kind of
being biased that's completely being
biased it's kinda yeah hey review this
cool we handled these thank you and then
delete the tweet and then yeah they're
so okay by 2020 requests from connected
actors to delete tweets were routine one
executive right to another more to
review from the Brighton team the other
team would come back handled you can see
that here more diffusion by the team
here are all these tweets
which means it's an ongoing it's a
business as usual transaction it's not
just like you broke the terms of service
[ __ ] on Twitter right no no it was a
concerted effort to make sure to it's
basically saying hey we got another one
all right I'll take care of it this is
problematic for our campaign can you
take care of this Twitter yes we will no
problem because it's already in the
machine
celebrities and owns a light could be
removed or reviewed at the behest of a
political party that's the biggest wow
that's the biggest thing yeah that's the
problem saying it straight up
um exactly so then they have James a
tweet
so here we go I grabbed the first one
under s i I don't know what that means
um defer to safety on the high profile
second one so they say here are two
other tweets this guy's Stephen Lou
hanian and there's James Woods down
there you know James Woods the actor I
think everyone knows James was right oh
[ __ ] he's a he's a big time Trump guy
big time Republican guy he was talking
about Hunter Biden stuff back then they
were deleting his tweets and banning him
from Twitter and there so the DNC is
basically like hey can you take these
down too whoa and then they're like
human people making these actual
decisions not just Bots but yeah wow so
nothing was actually being flagged it
was just that hey exactly I'm a person
in terms of service violation right I'm
a person and I want these things taken
down on the behest of a political party
okay Daddy here you go yeah it's an okay
Daddy did you guys uh watch the uh
broken with Mark Zuckerberg
podcast no I only saw collection so he
was asking him like he's a visit how
come during that time yeah he's like how
come during that time like yeah like the
hunter Biden stuff was like you know
just constantly being swept away and and
Mark Zuckerberg's response was like oh
we didn't know if it was like Russian
disinformation or whatever so we're just
trying to like make sure before it gets
too viral to put it aside so we could
settle it and then Rogan was like well
how come it's everything on one
political side that you do that to like
how come it's just one thing where it's
like everything on this side like like
let's squish it there's no such thing as
other therapies for covid besides
getting the vaccine like everything was
like being swiped away except for horse
paced yeah and uh he kind of like sets
some really smart but doesn't mean [ __ ]
type of EX political [ __ ] yeah and I was
like round about damn I think if you
really read between the lines these guys
are somehow owned by like one party one
really big party and censorship is such
a big deal
Elite yeah I mean what blows my mind is
before I mean like just when we were in
college
it felt like the um the Republicans and
the GOP were the ones that were
compromised during the Bush
Administration because his father was
the director of the CIA and then
um Bush Jr when he took over too it just
seemed like oh all that [ __ ] is just old
school [ __ ] politics well if you
remember even during this hunter story
like Republicans at the time were even
saying it's Russian disinformation yeah
like this was a concerted effort by
people who are you know holding their
power to say like hey you can't talk
about something that is that is true you
can't even talk about these photos that
are real it's Russian disinformation it
has all the Hallmarks of Russian
disinformation campaign signed by 50
Former Intelligence Agency officials and
nobody has to account for that by the
way I saw a guy he was one of those 50
and he was on like he was being
interviewed by a journalist and they
were like a TV guy and they were like
hey what was up with that he's like well
you can't prove that it wasn't true but
yeah yeah it has all the Hallmarks it
doesn't mean just because you guys are
so [ __ ] literal doesn't mean like
we're saying like yeah it's definitely a
Russian disinformation campaign so they
don't even have to own it because
nobody's gonna hold their feet to the
fire with the media it was photoshopped
they run the media dude we see it time
and time and time again that's why like
normies like they don't even know about
the hum like laptop [ __ ] or or if you
talked about it back then you're a
Russian disinfo guy or that Hunter is
even super involved in Ukraine yeah is
there any more stuff that he put up this
is it so far this is this is the full
thread so far what's your guys's
favorite part of the hunter Biden video
um I like seeing him topless at the
beach and then going in and out of the
water I'm okay I like that I like when
he's weighing out the crack
that's pretty cool I was like this is
tight I was like he's very scientific
about it yeah yeah I like how he fell
asleep with the crack pipe in his mouth
I like that that picture's sick I mean
someone took that picture yeah and
thought it was hilarious yeah and it was
he doesn't clean that pipe very much or
was it hilarious or was it blackmail
like we don't know I don't [ __ ] know
but that's the thing we want to talk
about all this other stuff why would you
take a picture of a guy with a crack
pipe in his mouth maybe it's for the
meme but it's in his computer so it must
have been someone who took it it's in
his computer and it's like they're
laughing at it yeah like we're all boys
like we're our [ __ ] we ride on each
other when we go to sleep but in these
guys's World they smoke crack together
but if I wanted Ray animate to know that
I [ __ ] own him for life I would take
a picture of him with a crack bite of
his mouth and I'd put it on his [ __ ]
hard drive on my own hard drive yeah so
then when you look at your pictures oh
so that you know that it might exist I'd
make it your screen I'd make it your
screensaver so every time you [ __ ]
computer goes to sleep it's just the
crack type oh no I own you how crazy is
it so this is what I'm saying how crazy
is it that you can have a picture of a
crack pipe in your mouth you can have
all these hookers around you and [ __ ]
and then the media is just like we're
not going to talk about it at all all of
us we're not going to talk about it but
let's talk about Kyrie Irving let's talk
about how Kanye Kanye West is a Nazi
lover
yeah it is more entertaining though you
know they just asked Elizabeth Warren
right they're like how do you feel about
elong taking over Twitter and she goes
no one man should have all this power
and everyone's laughing because they're
like well a lot of you guys been doing
the same [ __ ] what the whole time I know
except that was your goal it's so good
Oh I thought that was funny because that
was a Kanye lyric
so what do you think happens next maybe
a Christmas rapper
is there any repercussions for anything
will there be
maybe I'm Elon uh yeah yeah will they
come after they're gonna try to come
after him yeah what will happen for this
is they'll just say Elon sucks and like
you can't believe that he released all
this internal [ __ ] and so you don't
think they're gonna further investigate
uh both of Biden's involvement in
Ukraine and on stuff
um well I'll tell you this I'm not gonna
hold my breath about it yeah so you
think this is just something that's
gonna also get swept under the rug No
One's Gonna give a [ __ ] about it always
does
I don't think there's enough people that
care yeah so like I think there's more
now than ever before that half of the
people you talk to don't even know
what's happening yeah but I think most
people don't give a [ __ ] yeah
and it's because most people are busy
worrying about their own lives and [ __ ]
and then there there are probably some
people that like are on Twitter or like
but the ones that do need to know like
the ones that actually vote the senior
citizens they probably don't know any of
the [ __ ] that's going on well at least
they know about Trump Russia collusion
this question this is a little off topic
but do you think Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden have a good relationship with each
other
I think they have a great relationship
with each other they think their life's
proud I'm proud of us Joe Biden said
that his son's the smartest guy he knows
really yeah I mean right now this is
after the laptop [ __ ] what if he is just
a really smart play he just yeah he just
doesn't apply himself I love the way my
son smells
he doesn't snap his son Dade come on
let's not do misinformation he doesn't
he just likes to touch the hair sniffs
little tiny little kids yeah yeah that's
true little girls he's too old yeah
Hunter's too old for this yeah oh what's
that smell oh it smells like cigars or
something it smells like crack cocaine
oh that's what it is crack okay I want
to know some more [ __ ] though are they
gonna drop more it's just like that's it
um I don't know this is this is the
first drop this is huge that they've
been working in conjunction with each
other are they going to be now targeted
the removal of specific tweets that
offend a political party no but who's
gonna be held accountable is what I'm
asking is like would journalists come
after it investigate it would they try
to go up and see like you know like who
in the DNC we're calling these shots
we'll find out yeah uh maybe not though
it's gonna be more about how T Elon is
like ruining Twitter like that's gonna
what the news is usually yeah usually
yeah so interesting it's such a I don't
know I feel like it's such a shame that
like it's almost like people don't
deserve
freedom and democracy when like you're
given opportunities to run your own vote
do all these things and then you just
kind of like walk away from it isn't
Elon isn't Elon kind of proving like how
effective freedom of speech is with
Kanye as an example for like like Kanye
just
took a lot of freedom
well that's too much maybe but maybe a
little too much but but did he
promulgate ideas that are making people
do things or did he make a lot of people
go what the [ __ ] are you talking about
right yeah that's the difference that's
the difference you're seeing one play
out yeah yeah that's true what the [ __ ]
are you talking about Kanye and in the
public has enough sensibility to be like
Kanye you [ __ ] nuts bro yeah what are
you doing you don't have to silence them
you just everyone would just be like oh
you look at them talk enough you'll
realize how crazy someone is but I was
Joseph sitting next to you he's like I
don't know about that brother he's like
oh God Jesus when Alex Jones is trying
to protect you now you really know you
[ __ ] up
shut up and dribble Kanye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]